loading loading loading loading and it
says this house is spittin hey everybody
its charlie this house is bitchin so we
finally got all the answers we needed
and a really big teaser for season 5 so
we'll break everything down there were a
bunch of comic book Easter eggs in a
couple of changes especially to who
mystery girl wound up being so careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video starting with
number 10 Barry gets his job back /
captain's saying because of the articles
that iris was writing so you see how
they're fixing some of the storytelling
that they did this season
therefore shadowing that iris is gonna
be more of a writer next season and that
will be how she helps the group out they
actually had her do that a couple times
during the episode where she would use
her ability to communicate or write to
tell people or to either evacuate when
the satellite started to fall or just
alert people in general so I think it's
a much better way for iris to help out
in the group for people that thought it
was weird that she was doing a lot of
science-based things at STAR Labs but
she brings back Marley's so number 9
Marley's explains how DeVoe works why
they can't take him down shout out for
the Legion Cara
Oliver Wally none of them put together
would be enough to fight Devo in the
physical world which is why they need to
inception him invite him matrix style so
number 8 Barry goes into des Vosges mind
using a version of the comic book
thinker twist like he puts the thinking
cap on you see the wire sticking out of
his head it's right out of that geoff
johns comic book but you see why now it
was so important that Cecile be able to
read minds because they were building
towards this twist they use heard the
neural inhibitor from earlier the season
two Trojan horse buries consciousness
into Davos mind so what felt like they
kind of earned that cecile ability there
were a couple times this season when
people wondered what the side effects of
her having special powers would be like
is her baby gonna be a meta but I think
they did a pretty good job when they
started to examine the baby and they
said that it was going to be totally
normal no traces of dark matter
so the departure from the comic book
storyline is is that during that what he
did was is just have a giant matrix
battle with a thinker and then that was
the end of it it was more of a digital
matrix type story so you can see why
they went full matrix revolution
with the end of this story but before we
got to that number seven the Caitlyn
season five teaser so while they're all
preparing for Cecile to give birth she
grabs Caitlyn's arm and force mine reads
her and says something about Thomas he's
always been this way Thomas isn't a
character that we've heard about before
and remember she's pulling thoughts out
of Caitlyn's mind so Thomas is probably
going to be her father remember we just
got that new origin story for her saying
that she'd been a metahuman this whole
time either she was born one because the
DNA was passed from her parents or she
became when when she was a little girl
so more foreshadowing for season five
just teasing out more of Caitlyn's
backstory
maybe something secret will happen with
her father like maybe he also was a
metahuman and that's how she got her
powers so remember the name Thomas
important person for season five number
six though
Harrison wells forces Sisko to help him
use the thinking cap again and then
after which you know like he's able to
help Barry you need to go to the picnic
area they're playing the song so they
bring it back around from that devote
origin episode but they finally start to
pay off the berry gibberish from the
beginning of the season in a more
meaningful way and he just starts
speaking the same things that Barry was
speaking nor isn't supposed to be here
can you see the stars falling so
obviously those were references to
things that will be happening shortly in
the future I think we had the idea when
Barry first came out in episode 1 hey
you know the things he's talking about
they kind of sound like things are gonna
happen in the future we're gonna need
more diapers this house is bitchin there
were just a couple of those I felt like
they tried to seed those lines of
dialogue periodically in his non
spoilery way as possible like they
turned this house is bitchin into a joke
so that I think that you wouldn't pay
attention to it but they paid that off
with Nora at the end like hey this house
is bitchin speaking a little bit like
bart allen will talk all about her in a
second but number five this is actually
really cool
Davo explains why he never came for the
flash before that he had predicted
everything that was going to happen in
the Flash's abilities were something
that he did want but he didn't need to
go after the flash because the flash
would come to him one of the
eventualities that he had predicted was
is that they would try to inception him
so all he needs to do to take Barry's
power is to defeat him inside his mind
space the way that he defeated Ralph
so obviously I don't think that anybody
expected that DeVoe would defeat the
flash but you can imagine how bad things
would be if he had access to all of
space-time in the speedforce itself that
also might have something to do with
what's going on with season 5 when Nora
said she made a really big mistake
but of course number 4 we get Ralph back
and we get our really big matrix battle
they drop all kinds of references there
were so many Buffy jokes in this you
guys probably spotted the more obvious
ones he calls the Nexus a Hellmouth and
they also say there'll be no defeating
the Big Bad this season the term Big Bad
was something that was coined by Joss
Whedon during Buffy era it was meant to
be a version of what would happen when
the villain gained some extra power he
would go from being the bad to being the
big bad the villain becoming the
super-powered villain which is what
happened to devote this season he drops
another Star Wars reference Attack of
the Clones and you get your full neo
Matrix Revolutions fight but they also
do a little bit of Matrix Reloaded like
when he's spinning that big pull around
this time he's spinning Ralph's around
they make the big exit and you get that
Matrix Revolutions ending when neo
defeated Smith from inside like he
literally just takes him over only they
didn't do the explodey effect it just
Ralph changing his appearance back to
his normal one because this is Ralph's
body it's been DeVoe using Ralph's
powers to make himself look like he used
to look but you may notice that there
were a couple times during the episode
that they kept referencing we defeated
you together so it was all about them
doing a version of say like the season 1
ending when you have that big giant hole
in the sky and it was really flash in
the firestorm solving the ultimate
problem themselves and really just
firestorm if you want to be technical
about it because Ronnie sacrificed
himself to close that wormhole so you
get your parallel for number 3 very
supersonic punching the satellite that's
sort of a version of Ronnie dying during
season 1 Barry was supposed to die but
we get the surprise that Nora wins time
back adds her Speed Force power to his
and they're able to take it down with
their combined might so it's sort of
like a version of the season 1 ending
only a much happier ending because they
work together like they want to give you
that message we did it together but
number 2 Cecile gives birth to her baby
girl with Joe it's called Jenna Marie
West so obviously going to be older
then whatever nor Alan is going to be
because iris makes the joke about well
you know we're not gonna do this for a
long time but at some point we are going
to be next Barry and he starts getting
all flustered but aside from Wally
coming back and joking there aren't too
many things to let you know what might
be happening with the Jenna character in
this future timelines that Nora
referenced at the end of the episode
she's like I think I did something bad
dad
something real bad but because this baby
was such a big deal I wouldn't be
surprised if this Jenna baby character
in the future wound up being a part of
whatever that problem was here he goes
back to earth-2 to see Jesse quick they
explained that he's more balanced now
like he's basically a normal person
somebody who is kind of smart but not
genius level smart but also has gained
the people skills or become more in
touch with his emotion so he could just
interact with people without being a
total [ __ ] now so as far as I know
Tom Cavanagh is coming back this season
I assume it's gonna be this version of
the character they went so far to change
his personality that it feels like it
would be weird to then not bring him
back and give you that version of
Harrison wells so I'm assuming that this
is what he's going to be like next
season but number one of course that big
bomb that they dropped so obviously
there's all that language about iris
joking that they'll have children at
some point in the future knock knock
knock on the door she's wearing a
version of irises costume it makes sense
that they would give that to her we
don't know if she has a twin brother we
only know that there's her so what they
might be doing is just doing a
combination of Bart Allen because she's
from the future she speaks a lot like
Bart Allen this house is bitchin and
she's wearing a version of the XS
costume like iris did this is actually
the Photoshop that I did when that came
out now it didn't have the lightning
bolt on it when iris Ward but in the
future Nora might add the lightning bolt
when she quote/unquote borrows it from
iris but if you were confused about what
Wally was saying and whether or not he's
gonna go back on legends I think he's
just gonna bounce back and forth between
the shows they haven't made any official
announcements and when they released the
season 4 art Wally wasn't anywhere to be
found and they haven't said whether or
not he's gonna stay on the flash
full-time or beyond legends full-time so
we just assumed that he's gonna pop up
everywhere and it won't be that big a
deal but let's talk about Nora Allen so
when she says she messed up in the
future this could mean a lot of
different things the rumors for the
season 5 villain like cobalt blue or
maybe cicada or something like that
didn't really pan out the way I expected
them to and this is the quote from the
producer about the season 5 villain he
said you know pretty sure that it's not
going to be a speedster but early
predictions let me know in the comments
what do you think the problem that she
created is so I will post that season 5
video tomorrow no worries I'll name the
flash ring giveaway winner when I post
that so click here to listen to the
actress who plays Norah talked about
comic-con and season 5 stuff and click
here for all my Deadpool Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome this house is bitchin